Working retail, waiting tables, standing in
line at the amusement park or just shopping
with mom, anyone who’s ever been stuck on
their feet for a long time more or less standing
still knows that it’s much more tiring than
walking the equivalent amount of time.
But why?
First, when you stand, your legs aren’t
resting, even beyond just supporting your
weight.
Instead, your body sways very slightly.
To keep you upright, a few muscles, particularly
those in your calves, are constantly working,
making very small adjustments that you probably
aren’t consciously aware of.
On the other hand, when you walk, the burden
is distributed across more muscle groups.
Muscles swinging the arms help propel them,
core muscles keep you stable, butt muscles
complete your stride, and the legs of both
the calves and the thighs are employed.
Second, when you’re standing still, each
foot and leg supports about half of the body’s
weight, but neither ever gets a rest.
On the other hand, when walking, each time
a foot is raised the muscles formerly helping
to balance you get a little break as does
the bottom of your foot.
While only a small break each instance, this
totals to about half the time being in more
or less a resting state other than the muscles
required to lift your foot off the ground.
Third, when you stand, the blood and lymph
fluids pool in your feet, calves and ankles,
because your heart cannot efficiently pump
the blood all the way up from your feet by
itself.
This is why if you stand in one place for
long periods, you might notice that your feet
and lower legs swell a little.
Because the heart isn’t up to performing
this task efficiently, it relies in part on
muscle contractions that occur when you walk
and move about.
As David J Tibbs in Varicose Veins and Related
Disorders, states,
Only the peripheral pumping mechanism (musculovenous
pumping) can cause full venous flow against
gravity.
This forceful pumping action is brought about
when multiple veins are compressed by contraction
of surrounding skeletal muscle.
The valves direct the blood heartwards and
prevent it from falling back again.
Thus, by this simple arrangement, the harder
the muscles work, the more vigorously is the
massive flow of blood generated by this activity
returned towards the heart.
Thus, when you stand in one place, your muscles
are receiving less oxygen and other such things
they need to operate at peak efficiency compared
to when you walk around.
Fourth, when you stand, the entire load of
your body rests on the same place – the
underside of your feet, and particularly on
the balls and heels.
Beyond one side getting the aforementioned
break about half the time, when you walk,
different parts of your feet bear the load
at different times.
Fifth, standing is sometimes much more boring
than walking, particularly if you are at work
with nothing mentally engaging to do (or watching
your mom shop…).
With nothing to occupy your mind, it can wander
to how tired you are and how much your feet
hurt.
On the other hand, when walking, your brain
will be more occupied since you must constantly
assess the situation and avoid obstacles.
Thus, standing may also seem even more tiring
because you are just more aware of how your
legs and feet are feeling.
Sixth, if you walk fast enough (or jog), your
body will release neurochemicals that make
you feel better, including adrenaline that
pumps the heart faster, providing more oxygen
to the muscles and brain, as well as endorphins
that improve mood.